- You have some baby news, congrats!
- Yes, thank you!
- [Kelly] Yes, it's exciting.
- This is another big
addition to the family.
A lot of people may or may not know
that I had issues getting pregnant,
you know, when me and
my husband got married.
So we had did the IVF treatment,
and we got our son Ace.
He's three now and we wanted
to have another child.
We still had two more embryos from that.
And because I had a high-risk pregnancy
we were trying to figure out,
okay, what's the best
way to go about this?
And we decided to go with a surrogate.
And she decided to help me and my husband.
- That's amazing.
I love it 'cause you're
actually documenting it
on the show, right?
This season.
- Yes.
- And I think that's really important,
I have many friends that have suffered
from trying to have children,
trying, trying, and can't do it.
And like, it's a very important thing
to be confident and comfortable,
saying like, "Look, my
body, it wasn't made for,"
my body, by the way, was
not made for pregnancy.
I was hospitalized, it was horrible.
- Oh, my goodness.
- God bless surrogates.
- It's a very selfless act.
- My body, also not
made for pregnancy.
(all laughing)
(audience claps)
- It's a hard, if your
body, if it doesn't take,
it is like so hard on you.
So it's an amazing thing.
I think it's so awesome that
you're sharing that, that's a
very personal thing.
- Can I ask a question?
Will you go into the, will
you be there for the delivery?
- Yeah!
For sure, I mean, that's
a lot of what you'll see
on the show this season.
Like, you'll see we're going
to doctor appointments together,
we're, you know, just that whole process.
Because I don't think
anybody actually showed it,
because a lot of people
are quiet about it.
Like, honestly, I really
didn't even tell anybody
that we were expecting a
child until the show announced
that it was airing a new season.
Because I didn't really
know how to share that
with a lot of my friends even.
A lot of my friends were like,
"Wait a minute you're having a baby?"
You know, it was like
really crazy to them.
But at the same time,
I didn't really wanna hear
anybody else's opinion at first.
And so to do it--
You wanna do you.
- Yeah, to do it on the
show it's like a big deal
because it's like, you don't know
how people are going to comment.
Because, you know, the first thing--
- You're getting a beautiful child,
who the hell cares what they say?
- That is true, exactly.
(audience applauds)
Good point.
- And I think that you're, honestly,
that is a really touchy subject
with a lot of my friends.
- It is.
- That's like really hard.
Like for a woman, especially,
there's such a sense
of failure you feel, like
when you can't do it.
So it's really cool that
you're open about it.
- Thank you.
With my first child,
Riley, it was in my 20s,
you know, I didn't
really have to try hard.
But then, you know, later in
life when I met my husband,
I'm thinking that everything
was just gonna happen, and it didn't.
So I think a lot of women start
to have that struggle as they get older.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I didn't have
my kids till I was in my 30s.
It was, oh, and I didn't
ever look like that!
(all laughing)
Nope, definitely didn't!